bonsoir fm vous êtes donc sur place de
la république
quel est l'état d'esprit au lendemain de
ces violences qu'on a vécu en direct sur
rt france hier soir j'écoutais stéphanie
un rassemblement place de la république
avait été donné à 18h par plusieurs
associations du monde on utopia
concernant le lendemain de ces actions
qui a eu place de république
hier il était énormément de migrants à
s'être installés pour alerter les
pouvoirs publics sur leur situation
je rappelle que mardi dernier le camp de
saint denis qui abritait plus de 1500
migrants avaient été démantelées pour
prévenir les les pouvoirs publics
certaines associations avaient décidé de
rendre visibles ces migrants les
installant sur la place de la république
et c'était cette énonciation plutôt bon
enfant après quelques altercations avec
les forces de l'ordre qui ont essayé
d'arracher toutes les tentes et puis
dans la soirée
énormément de débordement des violences
policières des vans policières qui ont
bien sûr fait écho gérald darmanin le
ministre de l'intérieur avait été
questionné à l'assemblée nationale par
plusieurs députés
la france a en somme ils ont eric
coquerel et gérad à manas a déclaré que
l'igpn avait été saisie concernant ces
violences d'hier et puis aujourd'hui un
nouveau rassemblement a été organisé à
partir de 18 heures pour dénoncer ce qui
s'est passé hier et continuer d'apporter
le soutien aux migrants
et puis c'est un petit peu après à
partir de 20 heures que les choses ont
commencé à se tendre alors que tout
était plutôt bon enfant je vous propose
d'écouter quelques réactions qu'on a pu
avoir sur la place de la république
pense que ce qui s'est passé hier soir
ici bloche des rythmiques au niveau des
migrants ça résume vraiment bien ce qui
se passe en ce moment dans notre état
avec cette violence policière qui est
accrue qui est dépénalisée est
totalement invisibilité avec cette
nouvelle loi
cet acharnement contre ceux qui n'ont
rien et ceux qui sont déjà dans une
misère sociale que qu'on laisse de côté
depuis longtemps je pense que c'est
vraiment rond c'est en inadmissible et
c'est bon ça qu'on est là
j'aimerais bien qu'on retrouve vraiment
les bases d'une démocratie saine
et surtout j'aimerais bien qu'on soit
fidèle aux valeurs qu'on apprend à nos
enfants parce que liberté égalité
fraternité aujourd'hui la fraternité six
étapes et sur un être humain je la vois
pas si l'égalité c'est de laisser des
gens dormir dans la rue je les vois pas
si la liberté c'est être interdit de
manifester est interdit de filmer les
violences policières je ne la vois pas
non plus on traite des êtres humains
comme moins que rien c'est à dire mon
chat est mieux traité que ces gens là
moi je considère que l'accueil des
migrants en france est absolument
scandaleux pour le pays des droits de
l'homme je pense qu'on devrait être
exemplaire et la politique migratoire
tout compliquée qu'elle est mérite des
vraies solutions et pas de déloger des
gens qui étaient porte de la chapelle et
de s'en féliciter il ya une semaine pour
au final les sortir de leurs tentes et
leurs maîtres des lacrymo dans la dans
la tête alors qu'ils n'ont rien fait mon
dieu stéphanie beaucoup de soutien par
rapport à ces migrants par rapport à ces
sans papiers beaucoup de l'association
qui ont appelé à ce que le gouvernement
puisse prendre ses responsabilités et
puis un petit peu avant 20 heures les
choses ont été générés sur la place de
la république une manifestation sauvage
a été organisée énormément de personnes
ont pris la rue du temps paru à laquelle
on se trouve actuellement
ils ont voulu défiler sur cette rue du
temple il ya eu des poubelles qui ont
été incendiés et puis les forces de
l'ordre étaient barrage sur cet ordre du
temple
ils ont essayé de charger pour repousser
tous ces manifestants et les reconduire
en direction de la place de la
république pour l'instant le climat est
assez tendue ici place de la république
des jets de projectiles sont en cours
sur les forces de l'ordre que force de
loi qui ont barricadé complètement le
périmètre comme vous pouvez voir sur ces
images et ils ont commencé à préparer
déjà les canons à eau pour l'instant les
forces de l'ordre n'ont pas chargée
aucune violence policière pour le moment
il s'est juste de ddc de de quadriller
le périmètre est d'essayer de contenir
cette foule cette foule qui est comme
vous pouvez le voir actuellement le
cantonner sur la place de la république
les forces de l'ordre quadrillent
complètement tout ce périmètre
et puis pour le moment c'est ce qu'on
peut vous dire actuellement sur cette
situation qui est assez tendue un climat
assez tendu
ici place de la république